épuisé au sortir de leurs interventions
ces hommes reviennent tout juste du
sous-sol envahi de l'épaisse fumée noire
des conditions extrêmement difficiles
c'est un incendie en milieu très confiné
du coup c'est particulièrement difficile
pour nos hommes d'avoir une progression
vers l'est vers le feu pour l'attaquer
directement
il ya une très forte chaleur un
plusieurs centaines de degrés à
l'intérieur donc c'est très éprouvant
pour les sapeurs pompiers qui en plus
n'ont strictement aucune visibilité
puisque les fumées sont sont très
épaisse donc c'est aussi dangereux avec
aussi le risque éventuellement
d'explosion de réservoir donc c'est pour
ça que les sapeurs-pompiers progresse
prudemment avec prudence donc par deux
et reliées par un fil d'ariane tout au
long de leur progression les pompiers
équipés d'un appareil respiratoire ont
dû d'abord faire sortir les épaisses
fumées toxiques par les multiples
bouches d'aération afin de pouvoir
ensuite attaqué le feu au total ce sont
plus de 100 pompiers qui se relaient
depuis ce matin sur le terrain
[Musique]